so I'm doing acceptable games okay and
you can see a briquette of a pot into X
and the reciprocal of mod X okay so this
X basically pot I'm done he's familiar
with one over log X so rather than put
three computer graphs on to my cart into
flames
get really confused I'm going to do log
x over here and then do its reciprocal
and then once I'm doing what that
reciprocal looks like they're not put it
onto here and I will do the
multiplication okay so this is log X
right now I don't see here the order is
0 right that tells me that tells me that
I'm going to have a vertical asymptote
right for 1 over log X okay now what's
happening as I approach here as I
approach assassin sir well I'm
approaching 0 from below right which
means the reciprocal will approach
negative infinity okay you're right with
that I mean is that some time after all
but then what's happening as I go to the
left well log X is approaching negative
infinity right
so the reciprocal will approach 1 over
tiny number but negative okay now I
can't actually get to 0 it's a hollow
circle right but I can get arbitrarily
close as close as I want to right it's
like well how close to zero do you want
do you want to get to like minus 1 it
for a billion billion billion well just
go down far enough and you'll get it so
that's what this little bit looks like
what's happening over here this is the
easy this is positive and it's
approaching zero the denominator today
Paul that's approaching up that way and
then this guy grows he does very slowly
but he never stops so therefore this is
going to approach y equal zero as an
asymptote so now that blue graph I'm
going to put over here as my one of my
components okay so I've got this kind of
shape
and this kind of shape okay
so now when I think about multiplying
these together multiplying okay what's
gonna happen over here on the left
what's gonna tell me again remind me
what's the equation of that asymptotes
that I've just drawn in pathetic 1 x
equals 1 now if that's x equals 1 what
can you tell me about the ordinates here
and here and here and here tell me about
these orders they're all fractions there
are proper fractions they're all small
numbers right so therefore when I
multiply these smaller numbers by these
guys they're going to be smaller than
these right so that's gonna make it
above closer to the x-axis right
I still can't be equal to 0 right I'm
still gonna approach this asymptote
there and I'm going to approach it from
above this line can't you see that
that's a bit weird but that's how you
can oh yeah it's been squeezed in there
it's the bleep even in okay because
we've made that opposite argument with
whatever X okay then what happens over
here what happens over here now I think
you can probably see I'm gonna be
climbing off to infinity right because
this y equals x line it approaches 1
right so therefore it's not dropping
very fast so this guy which is growing
it's gonna take over okay but then the
question becomes well what about in here
I've got the same problem of increasing
versus decreasing and you have to ask
the question which one is going to take
over now he's how I'm gonna make the
argument okay again visuals right okay
which one is growing faster X or log X
it's gonna be this guy right this is
faster and this is slower right so this
goes faster and this one goes slower
right now therefore it says to reason if
you take reciprocals that means that
this denominator is going to
drink faster and this one will shriek
slower right it's actually a good it
ends up looking very very similar right
but that's enough to say this one 1 over
X is shrinking faster than 1 over log X
is shrinking ok now remember we're
comparing X with 1 over log X in X and
whatever X we multiplied you get a flat
line they're exactly them they're
exactly matched but 1 over log X isn't
pulling as hard right here is shrinking
but is shrinking slower ok therefore
therefore X is going to take over
he's going to be growing faster so you
end up getting this downward but he has
to turn he has to turn around like that
and again once we learn the calculus for
these functions will be able to
determine exactly where it shows that I
wouldn't be surprised if it was